y seguro que muchos de ustedes conocen
la historia de isaac newton que observó
una delgada franja de luz y colocó un
prisma en esa franja de luz y el prisma
separó la luz blanca en todos los
colores del arco iris si ustedes hacen
este experimento es probable que vean
algo como esto un rectángulo con todos
los diferentes colores del arco iris a
esto le llamaremos el espectro continuo
es continuo porque vemos todos los
colores sin interrupciones uno junto a
otro casi combinándose por eso se le
llama espectro continuo
si hiciéramos algo similar con el
hidrógeno no veríamos el espectro
continuo si pasáramos corriente en un
tubo que contenga hidrógeno como gas los
electrones en los átomos de hidrógeno
van a absorber energía y saltar a
niveles de mayor energía cuando esos
electrones regresan a nivel fundamental
emiten luz hablamos de esto en el vídeo
anterior cuando hablamos del concepto de
emisión si usáramos algo como un prisma
o una rejilla de difracción para separar
el espectro de luz del hidrógeno no
tendríamos un espectro continuo si no
estas cuatro líneas de color como vemos
líneas a esto se le llama espectro
lineal este es el espectro lineal del
hidrógeno vemos una línea roja que tiene
una longitud de onda de 656 nanómetros
también vemos una línea azul claro que
tiene una longitud de onda de 486
nanómetros hay una línea azul con
longitud de onda de 400 34 nanómetros
y una línea violeta con longitud de 410
nanómetros este espectro de emisión es
único para el hidrógeno por lo que esta
es una forma de identificar a los
elementos por lo que esto es algo
importante y ya que cada espectro lineal
es único es muy importante explicar de
dónde vienen estas longitudes de onda y
podemos hacer esto usando la fórmula que
redujimos en el vídeo anterior
llamamos a esta ecuación la ecuación
balmer redberg 1 sobre lambda lambda es
la longitud de onda de la luz emitida es
igual a r que es la constante de rivers
que multiplica a 1 / y al cuadrado y se
refiere al nivel más bajo de energía -1
/ j al cuadrado j se refiere al nivel
más alto de energía por ejemplo digamos
que consideramos un electrón excitado
que va de un nivel alto de energía en
donde m es igual a 3 hacia un nivel de
menor energía n igualados por lo que va
a emitir luz cuando haga esta transición
una representación gráfica de esto para
ayudarnos a calcular la longitud de onda
que se emite cuando una electrónica del
nivel n 3 al nivel m2 vamos a dibujar al
electrón aquí y la diferencia entre esos
dos niveles de energía será igual a la
energía del fotón así es como calculamos
la ecuación balmer risberg en el vídeo
anterior
ahora vamos a calcular la longitud de
onda de la luz emitida cuando el
electrón cae del tercer nivel de energía
al segundo nivel de energía
1 / lambda es igual a la constante de
reader como lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior es 1.097 por 10 a la 71 entre
metros
que multiplica a 1 entre y al cuadrado y
se refiere al nivel de menor energía en
este caso es cuando n es igual a 2 por
lo que ponemos 1 entre 2 al cuadrado
y a esto le vamos a restar 1 entre el
nivel de mayor energía que corresponde a
n igual atrás así que es 1 entre 3 al
cuadrado saquemos la calculadora para
hacer las cuentas 1 entre 2 al cuadrado
es un cuarto así que es 0.25 menos 1
entre 3 al cuadrado es 1 entre 9
lo que nos da 1.38 que se repite este 8
y si multiplicamos esto por la constante
de rivers 1.097 por 10 a las 7 nos da 15
2 361 1.11 que se repite vamos a
escribirlo y a redondear esta cantidad 1
entre lambda es igual a 1 523 611
y para obtener lambda solo tenemos que
calcular 1 entre este número lo que nos
da 6.56 por 10 a la menos siete que
ahora está en metros nuestra lambda es
igual a 6.56 por 10 a la menos 7 metros
hagamos un ajuste pongamos 656 por 10 a
la menos 9 metros que son 600 56
nanómetros
esta cantidad les suena familiar
regresemos a donde vimos estos 656
nanómetros 656 nanómetros es la longitud
de onda de esta línea roja por lo que
esta línea roja representa la luz que es
emitida por un electrón que cae del
nivel de energía 3 al nivel de energía 2
ahora regresemos aquí y dibujemos lo un
fotón de luz roja es emitido cuando un
electrón pasa del nivel 3 al nivel 2 y
esto explica la línea roja en el
espectro de hidrógeno como podemos
explicar las otras líneas del espectro
la azul claro la azul y la violeta
pues podemos usar esta ecuación poner
algunos números y calcular estos valores
estos son electrones que caen desde
niveles más altos de energía hasta el
segundo nivel de energía vamos a
dibujarlos en nuestro diagrama digamos
que un electrón cae del cuarto nivel de
energía al segundo nivel de energía y si
hacemos los cálculos veremos que la
diferencia de energía corresponde a la
longitud de onda de la línea de azul
claro que vamos a representar aquí y si
el electrón cae del nivel de energía 5
al nivel de energía 2 este corresponde
en la línea de luz azul del espectro
finalmente la línea violeta corresponde
a la emisión de un electrón que cae
desde el nivel de energía 6 al nivel de
energía 2 ahora sí podemos explicar el
espectro lineal de el hidrógeno que
podemos observar y ya que calculamos
esta ecuación de valmer redberg usando
el modelo de boro es el modelo de boro
lo que nos permite explicar estos
diferentes niveles de energía que vemos
así que cuando vemos el espectro de
líneas del hidrógeno es cómo ver los
niveles
de energía o al menos así es como me
gusta imaginarlo ya que es la única
forma real que tenemos de ver las
diferencias de energía la energía es
cuántica da a esto le llamamos la serie
de valmer para el hidrógeno pero hay
muchas transiciones que podemos calcular
por ejemplo calculemos la luz que emite
un electrón que cae del segundo nivel de
energía al primer nivel de energía
hagamos más espacio y dibujemos una
línea y de nuevo recuerden que esto no
está dibujado a escala ponemos el
electrón en el segundo nivel y va a caer
al primer nivel de energía de n 2 a n 1
calculamos esta longitud de onda 1 /
lambda es igual a la constante de read
ver 1.097 por 10 a las 7
uno entre metros y vamos del segundo
nivel de energía al primer nivel de
energía esto es 1 entre 1 al cuadrado
menos 1 entre 2 al cuadrado hagamos más
espacio y saquemos la calculadora 1
entre 1 al cuadrado es uno menos un
cuarto será punto 75 así que tomamos
punto 75 de la constante de risberg
vamos a calcular lo escribimos la
constante 1.097 por 10 a las 7
y ahora lo multiplicamos por punto 75 y
nos da
8 227 500 vamos a escribirlo 1 entre el
hambre es igual a 8 227 500 tomamos esto
y dividimos 1 entre esto
y nos da 1.215 por 10 a la menos 7
metros
lambda es igual a 1.215 por 10 a la
menos 7 metros si recorremos el punto
decimal acá y redondeamos nos quedan 122
nanómetros
pero esta no es una longitud de onda que
podamos ver estos 122 nanómetros caen en
la región ultravioleta y no podemos ver
esta región solo podemos ver el espectro
visible esto representaría una línea en
una serie diferente pueden usar la
ecuación balmer redberg para calcular
todas las otras posibles transiciones
para el hidrógeno lo cual está fuera del
propósito de este vídeo aquí quería
mostrarles que el espectro lineal de
emisión del hidrógeno puede explicarse
con la ecuación de valmer redberg la
cual surge del modelo de voz del átomo
de hidrógeno aunque el modelo atómico de
bourne no es real
nos permite deducir algunas cosas y
darnos cuenta de que la energía es
cuántica da